when it comes to housing combi blocks
get a bad rep we've all seen the
depressing images from the former soviet
states of decaying gray blocks under a
dark sky surrounded by dead vegetation
the whole of it looks less like a
residential area and more like a
resident evil map and no pun intended
however this impression may not be
correct what if i told you that comic
blocks aren't that bad actually on the
contrary they're pretty good both in
terms of architecture and city planning
in many cases they can even beat brand
new housing development but how is that
possible let's find out following the
second world war most people in central
eastern europe still lived in houses and
apartments that had very few to no basic
amenities that meant an outside toilet
no bathroom sometimes no separate rooms
even running water and electricity maybe
very often three or even four
generations shared a living space
together if you wanted to cook or heat
you had to chop some wood and make a
fire bathing was often done in a
portable water basin all in all in the
1950s central eastern europe most of the
population lived in near medieval
conditions even inside cities due to a
growing urban population
industrialization and world war ii
destroying significant amounts of the
housing stock there was a severe housing
crisis in many parts of the former
eastern bloc traditional brick buildings
however were slow to put up relatively
expensive and required a large workforce
to help alleviate these problems soviet
planners came up with the architecture
version of lego factories were built all
over the eastern block whose sole
purpose was to manufacture standardized
prefab concrete panels on an enormous
scale the idea was to build the
foundation of the future apartment block
and then just deliver a pile of prefab
panels to the site where workers keep
putting them together until they have a
building and in theory this would allow
them to put up a [ __ ] ton of buildings
quickly and cheaply and it worked from
the 50s all the way till the 80s
enormous amounts of affordable housing
was built in every major town and city
which effectively solved the housing
crisis so in terms of cost time and
capacity comi blocks did great the
buildings themselves are of reasonably
good quality after all they're big hunks
of concrete it's pretty hard to mess
that up of course there were some issues
such as top floor apartments leaking due
to faulty roofs or elevators being prone
to breakdowns but aside from such minor
issues the overall result is positive
and so as a consequ
consequently as we
all right it sounds like i need a bit of
relaxation but where are my headphones i
haven't seen them around in a while
hey scotty
have you seen my earbuds
what a predicament now normally this
would be an unpleasant situation but
today's video is sponsored by raycon who
were so nice to send me a pair of their
everyday earbuds i've been using these
earbuds for about a week now and i have
to say i'm very satisfied the earbuds
offer 8 hours of playtime with a total
of 32 hours of battery time enough to
keep me entertained for all my daily
activities the everyday earbuds also
have this super nice mate texture and
seriously i really like how they feel to
the touch both in your hands and your
ears they also have a built-in
microphone so you can take calls at a
press of a button and of course the
sound quality is great all the while
raycon start at half the price of other
premium audio brands and they also come
with a 45-day happiness guarantee so
click the link in the description or go
to byraycon dot com slash adam something
that's buy recon dot com slash adam
something to unlock exclusive deals up
to 20 of your rakon order thank you for
checking out raycon ads like this helps
support what i do and now back to the
program aside from architecture comic
blocks also had a strong social aspect
in budapest at the time of inauguration
the uipalota residential area mostly
housed families moving in from the
villages or the inner city peter horbad
a photographer was there in 1970 to
document the moving in process and learn
more about the new tenant's experiences
in practice he helped a dozen or so
families move in and in exchange he got
to take some pictures and ask a few
questions according to him during one
family's move-in their little daughter
after exploring the whole apartment
reported to her parents in a state of
amazement that the apartment has
multiple rooms the photographer's own
grandmother also told a story about his
mother and aunt back then the same age
as that little girl but it was almost
impossible to drag them out of the
bathroom they were completely astounded
by it since in their previous apartment
in the 7th district they could only
bathe in a hand-held basin for the new
tenants comey blocks were near science
fiction moving out of a dark damp smoky
apartment without a toilet into a brand
new bright modern apartment with every
immunity inside for a lot of people
comic blocks represented a
civilizational leap forward but the real
secret of comedy blocks is in the
individual buildings as i mentioned in
terms of quality of life comic blocks
can beat even brand new housing
development and this is possible because
of the urban planning surrounding them
in hungary and across the eastern bloc
the new residential areas were built
based on so-called complete planning the
designers paid attention not just to the
amenities and services inside the
buildings but also outside them inside
most of the soviet-era residential areas
to this day there are kindergartens
schools doctors offices post offices
sports fields parks supermarkets and so
on everything you need for living in a
city or within walking distance from
your home or accessible through public
transportation the latter provided
comfortable access to the rest of the
city great in terms of urban mobility in
many areas this street plan was such
that it didn't allow through traffic
which was an early iteration of
superblocks how cool is that since then
the soviet times came to an end a good
reduce if you ask me but for all its
negatives like the one party system the
media censorship the police state
institutionalized corruption nepotism
and so on housing stands out as a rare
almost universal positive today in the
wake of regime changes and economic
upheavals many prefab residential areas
have seen better days but with proper
landscaping and renovation including
facade insulation these buildings can
stand up to the best newly built what
many tenants of new developments find is
that their neighborhood was built not
for the sake of housing first and
foremost but for making a profit as a
result if the local legislation allows
many developers skimp on the public
services and amenities and just focus on
squeezing as many units as they can on
the parcel this can result in new
development like this one with ground
floor courtyard-facing apartments that
are best suitable for vampires because
you won't be seeing any sunlight there
and this tightly packed quote-unquote
luxury development is just a few meters
away from the comic blocks with plenty
of space greenery and amenities between
them all in all combi blocks are pretty
good at least they can be but for that
the city and the tenants need to invest
in the area thankfully this is already
happening throughout central eastern
europe with germany having the wildest
ideas in terms of renovation and also
countries like ukraine starting to catch
up future prospects in my opinion could
even include full-on car free
neighborhoods with additional vehicle
attacks and parking fees to further
disincentivize car ownership and how
cool would that be comey block
neighborhoods paving the way to the
future of urbanism thank you for
watching don't forget to like and
subscribe and do check out my patreon if
you wish to support me making this kind
of content and i'll be seeing you next
time